>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR OUR
"SEEN AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT WHERE
WE REVEAL THE STORIES BEHIND THE
HEADLINES AND FOR THAT WE TURN
TO FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
RAYMOND ARROYO.
RAYMOND, HILLARY IS NOT BACK
WITH A NEW STREAMING SPECIAL,
THAT CAN'T BE HAPPENING.
>> SHE IS, LAURA, SOMEONE WHO
ONCE ASKED WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES
IT MAKE?
HILLARY AND HER DAUGHTER ARE
LAUNCHING THIS APPLE PLUS
SPECIAL CALLED GUTSY.
I THINK THAT ANYBODY WHO SITS
THROUGH THE SPECIAL IS GUTSY.
>> SHINING A LIGHT ON WOMEN WHO
INSPIRE US TO BE BOLDER AND
BRAVER.
>> THE GUTSY ESTATE EVERYTHING
YOU DID WAS STAY IN A MARRIAGE.
IT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S RIGHT FOR
EVERYBODY.
>> LAURA, FIRST OFF, WHO MADE
HILLARY CLINTON THE CURATOR OF
BOLD AND INSPIRING WOMAN?
I WILL LET YOU ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
YOU WROTE THE BOOK, WHY DID YOU
THINK SHE STAYED IN HER
MARRIAGE?
>> Laura: U.S. SENATE SEAT,
PRESIDENTIAL AMBITIONS, LET ME
COUNT THE WAYS.
JUST A COUPLE IDEAS, COUPLE
IDEAS.
>> ABOUT INSPIRATIONAL WOMEN
FOR OUR DAUGHTERS TO LOOK UP
TOOL, YOU THINK HILLARY WOULD
AVOID A WOMAN WHO BROUGHT US
"WAP," MEGAN THE STALLION, AND
ANOTHER WOMAN WHO MADE HER NAME
FROM A SEX TAPE.
>> WHEN ONE IS BEING FACED WITH
DEADLY FORCE OR BELIEVES DEADLY
FORCE IS IMMINENT.
>> I WAS REALLY INTRIGUED BY HOW
WELL SHE DID.
I WANTED TO PUT THE SPOTLIGHT ON
HER...
SHE NEEDS IT.
>> THE SPOTLIGHT ON HER?
HILLARY IS PUTTING THE SPOTLIGHT
ON HERSELF.
THE FACT SHE LOST A LEGAL QUIZ
TO KIM KARDASHIAN IS RATHER
EMBARRASSING.
CHELSEA SAID IT'S BECAUSE HER
MOTHER HAD A BAD BUZZ HER HAND I
THINK SHE'S GOT A BAD -- WILL
LEAVE THAT ASIDE.
>> Laura: I THINK
KIM KARDASHIAN'S PRETTY SMART.
SHE BUILT A MASSIVE EMPIRE AND
AN INTERESTING BEGINNING FOR
SURE, BUT SHE'S PRETTY -- I
THINK SHE'S REALLY SMART.
>> AND AUNT OF A NEWER, NOBODY
CAN TAKE THAT AWAY FROM HER.
IF YOU NEED A REMINDER WHY
HILLARY IS STRAINING TO STAY ON
THE PUBLIC RADAR, THIS IS WHY.
TAKING THE STAGE TO MARYLAND TO
WHIP UP THE BASE, IT WAS AN
ANGRY, LOUD, CRANKY SPEECH
DEVOTED TO TOUT HIS SPENDING
BILLS.
>> IT'S A BIG DEAL.
IF WE HAVE TO TAKE ON THE
CLIMATE DENIERS.
GUESS WHAT, WE BEAT THEM.
WE BEAT THEM.
THE MAGA REPUBLICANS ARE A
THREAT TO OUR VERY DEMOCRACY.
IF THEY REFUSE TO ACCEPT THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE.
THEY EMBRACE POLITICAL VIOLENCE.
>> LAURA.
>> Laura: WHY DOES HE TALK
LIKE THIS ALL THE TIME?
OUR BILLS ARE GREAT!
>> BUT IT'S A REAL TURNABOUT TO
TRY TO SUGGEST THAT IT'S
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE EMBRACING
VIOLENCE, LAURA, AFTER WE SAW
THE SUMMER OF RAGE, MONUMENTS
BEING TOPPLED, CITIES BURNED,
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES TARGETED,
PRO-LIFE CLINICS AND CHURCHES
DEFILED.
IF WHO'S EMBRACING VIOLENCE?
COME ON.
>> Laura: THAT'S ALL
JUSTIFIABLE AGAINST THE
OUTRAGEOUS DOMESTIC TERRORIST
CLASS.
RAYMOND, I HEAR YOUR MIRROR DOWN
IN NEW ORLEANS LaTOYA CANTRELL
IS UP TO INTERESTING THINGS.
SPEAK A LITTLE HOT WATER AFTER
CARJACKINGS INCREASED BY 400%
SINCE 2019
THE MAYOR APPEARED IN COURT
RECENTLY IN DEFENSE OF A YOUNG
CARJACK HER, THE VICTIMS.
>> I WAS IN SHOCK, SHE WASN'T
THERE FOR US, SHE WAS THERE FOR
THE ASSAILANT AND HER MOTHER.
IT FELT LIKE SHE WAS SUPPORTING
THE CRIME.
>> NOW MAYOR'S RESPONSE TURNS
OUT THAT THIS YOUNG OFFENDER WAS
FOUND GUILTY OF ROBBING MULTIPLE
WOMEN IN CARJACKINGS.
HE HAD BEEN THROUGH A CITY
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM THE MAYOR
FOUNDED IN 2019.
THE MAYOR USED HER OFFICE TO
DEFEND THE PERPETRATOR.
>> I DIDN'T PICK A SIDE, THAT
WAS MY WAY OF SUPPORTING THIS
YOUNG PERSON THAT WAS REQUIRED
TO PARTICIPATE IN A PROGRAM THAT
THE CITY OF NEW ORLEANS HAD
CREATED AND IS FUNDING.
THAT SUPPORTING A YOUNG PERSON
THAT HAS MADE DECISIONS THAT
PUTS HIM ON A BETTER PATH WAY.
THAT'S WHAT I DID.
>> NO, THAT'S REALLY NOT WHAT
SHE DID.
IF YOU'VE GOT A MULTIPLE
OFFENDER WHO IS BEAT UP AND
ROBBED MULTIPLE WOMEN AND TAKEN
THEIR VEHICLES, THEY SHOULD BE
THROWN IN JAIL.
THAT'S THE BEST PATHWAY, NOT
ALLOWING YOUR CITIZENS TO BE
VICTIMIZED TWICE BY PAYING FOR
THIS CRIMINAL DAY CARE AND BEING
ROBBED AT GUNPOINT.
>> Laura: WHAT DID HE LEARN IN
THE INTERNSHIP?
THAT'S MY QUESTION.
>> APPARENTLY THAT THE MAYOR
WILL SHOW UP AND PLEAD YOUR CASE
IN PERSON.
>> Laura: INTERESTING SKILLS
LEARNED IN THE INTERNSHIP,
COURTESY OF